ma petite fille va disparu monsieur
je veux qu'on me le ramène au plus vite
et vous discutez vous monsieur
vous êtes d'après ce qu'on m'a dit
l'homme de la situation
chaque bras est équipé d'un dispositif
explosif votre pantalon est également
équipés d'explosifs au
sérieux
là de l'endroit où nous nous tenons ce
moment
une pension d'euros où règne le mât
c'est quoi ça au bout de cinq jours et
si vous n'êtes toujours pas revenue avec
bérénice
vous avez compris l'idée je crois que
dieu vous garde
nous sommes au ghost landes ici mon ami
terre sans scission
ce n'est pas nous qui la retenaient
captifs
[Applaudissements]
ça pète deux jours
elles manquent toujours à l'appel
[Musique]
je fais pas obtus à est ici
il devait succomber à la
ans
valence
je suis
non
radioactifs personne ne s'échappe du
gothard
personnes
c'est plus une prisonnière
[Musique]
je vais vous donner la meilleure chance
possible de tomber enceinte qu'est-ce
que vous invite
vous êtes entre bonnes mains et
idéalement
des mains chaudes
vous êtes enceinte à 100%
salut papa
près d'une femme sur cinq souffre de
dépression près partout pensais pas que
c'était aussi fort la momie brain
je m'arrête pas vous inquiéter
vous devriez essayer de profiter d'un
peu de calme vous l'avez mérité
[Musique]
souriez lui si
ça rend vraiment plus heureux c'est
prouvé par la science
les risques de complications augmentent
significativement l'est chez le docteur
indoor je me sens pas bien du tout
confrontée en vous ce qui vous bloque
dans votre propre corps
suis parfois elle s'est occupée de me
faire croire que je suis
[Musique]
tu tentes la poisse mec ouais ouais mais
c'est super méchant c'était en foutent
quoi
j'ai un truc entre que chan pas se
dégage quelque chose de malsain
et en exclusivité sur ce plateau
carcéral
carcérale c'est 13 bis de platine et 13
condamnations
guillon quelque chose réalisateur
tolérant je suis un réalisateur tolérant
il vient d'y avoir en direct sur votre
télé un attentat envers l'intégrisme
dégressif sait comment ça s'appelle ce
qui vient de s'offrir un moment de grâce
j'allume la télé pour regarder ma série
sont là qu'il ya des méchants la
deuxième est méchant et
des vidéos de nous partout à la télé sur
internet ils disent qu'on est les
méchants et qu'on va faire sauter la
planète
travail
les deux individus qui sont à vos toiles
sont recherchés de pâtes
je mate ou basse mais vous êtes expert
oui je suis expert de voix font des
méchants barbus je suis déjà ma garde
négociations seraient vient du latin est
négociable et dans le monde du show
business je vais vous dézinguer la
gueule ça a très bien se passer
on a peur de la police avait dit à kiel
avec ta tête de puces ou là ce que je
peux vous poser une question qu'est ce
qu'ils ont acheté exactement un jus
antioxydants
antioxydantes non non mais comme ne
commençons pas à accuser les gens sur
des mauvais jeux de mots
[Musique]
gentils nous à la base
joyeux anniversaire mon amour les choses
ne vont pas bien entre nous et j'en suis
désolé
je sais que cette surprise ne réglera
pas tout en un clin d'oeil je t'aime de
tout mon coeur
jusqu'à ce que la mort nous sépare
[Musique]
je suis impressionné que ce soit arrivé
jusque là
j'ai une dernière surprise
s'en ira pas tant qu'on n'aura pas
ouvert le coffre
deux cent mille dollars joli diamant on
se partage les diamants allons-y ya deux
personnes qui connaissent la combinaison
du coffre le gars qui vous a engagé et
la fille elle doit être à des kilomètres
maintenant
elle est toujours dans la maison
[Musique]
plus personne ne sera blessé
ils veulent que tu cries
[ __ ] [ __ ]
anniversaire
le couple parfait
j'ai coupé la main pour me libérer toi
s'il me reste pas d'autres solutions
[Musique]
comment ça il faut que je t'amène à
l'hôpital
j'aurais jamais les moyens de payer
cette opération
[Musique]
et vous avez oublié quelque chose
tu es rapide tu cherches un nouveau
travail ça consiste en quoi à reprendre
au vif ce qu'ils ont volé aux pauvres
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la ligue
à l'ont détroussé tout c'est leur but
les amis
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vous faites j'ai
quelque chose qui vous appartient
est ce que vous diriez de sortir de
votre prison dorée
je vais te faire découvrir la ville
comme tu ne l'a jamais vu
j'aurais aimé que ceux qui ne s'arrêtent
jamais nue je dois te dire quelque chose
mes parents m'ont promise à un autre
arkadi ma demande et hama
et je dis oui
et ce n'est pas tout
[Musique]
nous allons nettoyer les rues de la
ville de toute cette racaille il est
temps de choisir entre ton destin tout
tracé la liberté
[Musique]
oui tous nos oppose
tu es né dans un palais et moi dans la
rue
et pourtant tout nous pousse l'un vers
l'autre
j'ai vu quelque chose changer dans ton
regard
et j'ai réalisé à quel point tu dis plus
une petite fille
[Musique]
ne vit pas en fonction des règles de
quelqu'un d'autre
écris ta propre histoire
dans la cité des glaces
tous les rêves sont réalisables
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça ça vient de là
où
moi
depuis le jour où mon père n'a adopté
je me suis entraîné pour devenir un
grand aventurier comme l'i
premier candidat au parc ligue 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hopper chicken sonne c'est quoi ce nom
au fait moi ces mecs
pourquoi pas comme tout
des choses qui nous rend différents sont
innovants d'exceptionnel
quartier tu sais que j'ai toujours rêvé
d' aventure nous allons découvrir le
plus fabuleux trésor de tous les trous
et c'est le cas de celui qui veut
accéder au temple du hamster des
ténèbres devra triompher de trois
épreuves mortelles pourquoi toujours 3
pourquoi c'est jamais deux épreuves
mortelles
[Musique]
c'est parti
e
non
je t'aime tu pousses comme personne
l' aventure j'en ai peur dos
je me fais invisible c'est ça le plan
tout le monde est à prévoir je te dirai
pas où tu fais
ok donc que vous avez arrêté là et de
moi s'il vous plaît
est en état d'arrestation
al'heure théodore pourquoi je vais te
faire enfermer dans une scierie tout le
monde le sait le tuèrent
[Musique]
il nous a presque tué
qu'est ce que tu as fait j'ai fait ce
que j'avais à faire
pour te retrouver teddy
légendaire bob physique tient ainsi qu
aux pattes
suis un professionnel la fesci les
mauvaises personnes et je vais tuer
lâche cette arme personne tue personne
ici
au
jeu devrait savoir ce qui te passe par
la tête en ce moment
où
voilà
obsa fois
est-ce que c'est grave crise qui titille
haute et 10 ont tonné l'âme je réponds
aux plus amicales et moins formels tony
et c'est aussi ne touche pas à mon
contrat je peux passer un contrat
concurrence c'est-à-dire que plusieurs
personnes veillent à un certain théodore
- tous et bob est ce qu'on va devoir se
battre en duel
fais moi sortir d'ici
toujours et seulement un pro tour de
tennis
et ils pourraient tous deux temps forts
et voilà
faisons un marché j'ai beaucoup de
pognon y a pas de marché affaire
balotelli
tu connais les règles
je dois tout savoir qu aurait dû me
laisser lui mettre une balle dans la
tête quand j'en avais la chance
[Musique]
c'est tendre besoins des grands
je n'est entré que tu le veuilles ou non
à
tu vois la différence ça c'est un
psychopathe war
une rue des passants des fenêtres ce que
tu vois c'est des menaces potentielles
alors tu m'achètes
[Musique]
j services de cloud peut pas longtemps
ouais les mecs avec qui je le sais
[Musique]
moi je suis à rendre à la france le pas
le mois mais toi tu fous là
je suis là c'est tout
vous avez vu des femmes dans l'armée
française moi j'ai vu des soldats vous
êtes un soldat mais moi mon nom sortez
vous les doigts du cul en fait moi je
portais quand var on a tous des
problèmes mais quand tu arrives au
régiment tu les laisses derrière toi est
ce que tu sais pourquoi portant
l'uniforme pour uniformiser justement
donc je veux pas savoir ce qu'il ya dans
ta tête je veux pas savoir ce qui se
passe chez toi en fout de savoir tout
bientôt ça va bien je sais pourquoi je
suis un matin j'ai pris peur
jean seront pas tout juste un acte est
un mini putt anéantir l'humanité en deux
secondes
hier qui pourra
[Musique]
non je crois
ce péché mon père que d'espérer un grand
amour quand je déciderai du pur génie
notre mauvaise fortune en fait même pas
convoiter mieux vaut mieux attendre pour
viser mieux alors voilà tout là vers 2
en l1
immeuble à paris je serais pour vous
forme d'accomplissement
razzia la boucherie tout leur viande
lyon s'est bien relancé cet argent qui
voudraient de moi s'il ne respecte pas
l'argent mais peu inspiré au bonheur
je suis char levant des fils de votre
frère
si vous le souhaitez cet après midi je
vous emmènerai voir le pays volontiers
vous n'avez jamais quitter ces lieux
parce que vous croyez qu'on m'y autorise
je vous montrerai paris un jour rappelez
vous tout cela de la tête puis tu
connais un pin
on jase beaucoup en ville sur la façon
dont vous traitez votre fille ce que
l'idée est rapide des jarres à chaque
pas un lit armes sortir de ma poche pour
acheter un mariage à ma fille ni
et enfin de vous sortir avec mon neveu
pour faire courir les rumeurs les plus
folles dans un mur
il va devoir partir qui ne l'a plus
jamais
puisque les pontons de ne rien attendre
pour une femme si ce n'est la volonté
des hommes de tous les hommes
aucune société l'inspecteur de
fréquenter une femme seule croyez vous
que j'en ai besoin de cette société
[Musique]